اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ بسؤالك عن أه
إعادة فتح فكرة التطبيع، حيث
كان هذا على ما يبدو مطروحًا عمليًا على الطاولة
قبل 7 أكتوبر، ومن الواضح أنه
كان كما تعلمون "اكتسحت بعيدًا" في هذه الأثناء،
ما رأيك في إثارة هذا الأمر
الآن بشكل
جدي ولم يكن كذلك على الإطلاق  مغلق
أه مسيحي كانت هناك عدة
تصريحات أه
قبل وبعد 7 أكتوبر عندما
أكد المسؤولون السعوديون أن التوصل إلى
تسوية للقضية الفلسطينية
سيؤدي إلى التطبيع والاعتراف المتبادل
مع إسرائيل كما تعلمون
هذا هو الأساس الكامل لمبادرة السلام العربية
التي طرحتها المملكة
منذ 21 سنة ورفضت إسرائيل
أن لا يغلق ذلك الباب أبدا
أه ربما الضروري الآن
بدلا من أن يرمش الوزير
يندب موت
الفلسطينيين ربما يمضي قدما
في تنفيذ
قرار الأمم المتحدة الذي يدعو إلى  إن الاعتراف
بالدولة الفلسطينية هو
السبيل الوحيد لوقف الصراع
نهائيًا، كيف يمكنك الانتقال من هناك إلى
هنا الآن في خضم هذه
الحرب غير المسبوقة حقًا، والأحداث الكارثية التي وقعت في
السابع من أكتوبر، وأنت تعرف
الآلاف والآلاف وفقًا لـ
الضحايا الفلسطينيين داخل غزة،
كيف يمكنك وضع الدولة وإنهاء
الاحتلال مرة أخرى على
الطاولة بكل بساطة، يمكنك ببساطة
الإعلان عن ذلك، كما تعلم أن هناك قرارًا للأمم المتحدة
يعود إلى عام
1948 181، وأعتقد أن
الجمعية العامة هي التي دعت  من أجل
إنشاء دولتين في فلسطين،
دولة فلسطينية ودولة إسرائيلية،
استمر الإسرائيليون بالطبع
وأقاموا تلك الدولة التي
لم يفعلها الفلسطينيون الآن يمكنك القول ببساطة أننا نعود
إلى القرار 181
وستخرج الدولة الفلسطينية.
لا يتطلب الأمر سحرًا أو منطقًا عينانيًا
أو عبقرية أه لمعرفة مخرج
نعم ولكن أعني أنك تعلم أن الحقيقة هي
أن ذلك كان مطروحًا على الطاولة
لفترة طويلة ولم يحدث
وهناك مقترحات سلام لا نهاية لها بما في ذلك المقترح الذي
قدمته  ذكرت للتو أن المملكة العربية
السعودية قدمت عرضًا في
عام 2002 أه والآن لدينا هذه
الحرب الرهيبة لذلك أعتقد أنه نظرًا لتجربتك،
أتساءل فقط عما إذا كنت ترى أي
مخرج سياسي وربما تعلم بقدر ما
يبدو أن هذه
الكارثة الرهيبة قد تؤدي إلى
حل سياسي  أم أن هذا مجرد حلم بعيد المنال،
سيتعين علينا أن ننتظر ونرى،
هناك الكثير من الحديث الذي أه
يطرحه الأمريكيون من قبل الأوروبيين حول
حل الدولتين لكنهم كانوا
يتحدثون دون السير على الطريق  أعتقد أن
ما هو مطلوب منهم هو أن
يضعوا أقدامهم جانباً وأن يمضيوا
قدماً ببساطة وأن يعملوا مع المملكة العربية السعودية والدول
الأخرى في المنطقة لإقامة
دولة فلسطينية وإنهاء
القتال، وأول شيء مهم
يجب القيام به هو التوقف.  إن القتل
هو أمر
لم تصل إليه أمريكا وأوروبا بعد
كضرورة فورية وأعتقد أن هناك ما يمكن إلقاء
اللوم عليه على الغرب أكثر من
أي شخص آخر، فأنت تدين حماس بشدة
ولكنك كتبت أيضًا أنك
أعلم أنني سأفهم هذا الأمر بشكل صحيح حتى
لا أخطئ في نقلك، لقد اتهمت حماس
بتخريب عملية السلام أه ولكنك
كتبت أيضًا أنهم وضعوا
الأم الفلسطينية في مقابلة حديثة
أيقظت العالم على وجود
قضية فلسطينية  أريدكم أن
توضحوا ذلك قليلاً لأنني أعني دعونا
نواجه الأمر، أنتم جميعاً أيضاً لديكم الكثير من
القوة ولم يكن هناك قدر كبير من
أه الحب للقضية الفلسطينية عندما
قامت الإمارات العربية المتحدة بتطبيعها ومن
يدري إذا كان ذلك  لولا هذه الحرب الآن،
ما إذا كانت المملكة العربية السعودية ستصر على
إنهاء الاحتلال في
الدولة الفلسطينية كما
يقول الجميع الآن مقابل
التطبيع، حسناً، ولهذا السبب يجب
وضع حماس تحت السيطرة حتى
لا تتمكن من ذلك.  يكون أه مفسداً لأي
حل سلمي للمشكلة الفلسطينية ولكن
الطريقة التي ترك بها الوضع مع
إضعاف إسرائيل
للسلطة الفلسطينية والحقيقة هي أن إسرائيل هي
التي تمول حماس بجلب
الأموال وتسليمها إلى
شعب حماس  نتنياهو جعل ذلك
ممارسة سياسية أساسية قام بها
لسنوات عديدة وهذا أمر غير مقبول ومن
ثم نرى النتائج أه
مزيد من الصراع والمزيد من التردد
والمزيد أه كل شيء يطير في
الهواء ولكن الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنك من خلالها التوصل إلى
حل  هو أنه إذا رجعت إلى
أصول المشكلة، فالمشكلة
هي احتلال إسرائيل لفلسطين، ويجب على
إسرائيل أن تتخلى عن فلسطين حتى
يتم وضع القضايا الأخرى في مكانها الصحيح
عندما تقول تخلى عن فلسطين، هل يمكنك أن
تكون واضحًا؟  بخصوص ما تعنيه
جيدا عليها أن تنسحب
وفقا لقرارات
مجلس الأمن 242 338 وأه
مبادرة السلام العربية وخريطة طريق
اللجنة الرباعية كل الحلول موجودة
تعرف تحدد كيف يمكن لإسرائيل
معكم أن تغادروا فلسطين  لتصبح
دولة أه ليس أه شيء
معجزة يجب القيام به لذلك
كنت رئيس المخابرات لفترة طويلة
وكنت تعرف منذ
فترة طويلة التعامل مع هذه القضية
وغيرها الكثير في المنطقة
أم عندما  ترى قلت إنك تعلم أن حماس
بحاجة إلى السيطرة عليها وهذا
ما تقول إسرائيل إنها تحاول أن تفعله
وتفعله في غزة يقولون إنهم فعلوا ذلك
أعتقد أنهم يقولون إنهم فككوا
أه سيطرة حماس على الأقل في أجزاء أو
كلها  شمال
غزة، هل تعتقد أن هذا سيكون
ما يفعله؟
لا أعتقد أن إسرائيل تستطيع أن تفعل ذلك، يجب أن
يفعله الشعب الفلسطيني،
فهم لن يسمحوا
للإسرائيليين بالقيام بأمورهم نيابةً عنهم أه
هناك  يجب أن يكون كما ذكرت ويجب أن
يكون هناك اعتراف بدولة
فلسطين ووقف
القتل ويكون وقف إطلاق النار في
غزة ومن ثم يمكن الحديث عن كيفية
اتخاذ الإجراءات من هناك أه
وعلى حماس أن تعلن اصطفافها
مع السلطة الفلسطينية، وعليها أن
تتخلى عن مواقفها السابقة بعدم
قبول حل سلمي مع
إسرائيل، وهذه أمور يمكن
حلها، ولكن بمجرد تطبيق وقف إطلاق النار،
يمكننا ذلك  العمل
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الولايات المتحدة والأمم
المتحدة ومعرفة كيف يمكننا
المضي قدمًا، لذا تحدثت عن المثيرين للاهتمام
منذ قليل، لكن هل ترى
أي
دليل حقيقي وهل أنت قلق من أن
الأمر برمته قد يتحول إلى حرب أوسع نطاقًا
وأنا  لقد أدرجت للتو عدد
البلدان التي شهدنا فيها
أنشطة عسكرية في الأسبوعين الماضيين فقط، حيث
ضربت إيران
باكستان والعراق، وأنت تعرف
أماكن أخرى، ماذا ترى، ومن
الواضح أن حزب الله الإسرائيلي يتاجر
بإطلاق النار فيها  الحدود الشمالية هناك هل
تراها تتحول إلى
أزمة أوسع أتمنى لا لكن لا أعتقد أن
الإيرانيين يرغبون في أزمة أوسع لا
أعتقد أنهم يريدون أن يتم قصفهم مثلا
أه من إسرائيل أو من الولايات المتحدة
ولهذا يستخدمون ميليشياتهم
سواء كانت الحسبة في لبنان أو
الحواشي في اليمن أو بعض الميليشيات
في العراق أه لتنفيذ أوامرهم أه
رأينا للتو أول أمس وأعتقد
أمس أه إيران تطلق صواريخ أه
و طائرات بدون طيار إلى العراق و إلى
باكستان أه هذا غير مقبول على الإطلاق
لكن أه شيء هذه هي
الأدوات التي تستخدمها إيران لتحقيق
أهدافها لا أعتقد أنها تريد
المواجهة مع الولايات المتحدة على
الأقل ليس إلى هذا الحد  إلى
حرب مباشرة مع الولايات المتحدة